in this video you're going to learn how
to rationalize the denominator so what
does that mean to rationalize the
denominator let's take a look at four
examples so you can see how to work with
this so first of all we don't want a
square root or a cube root in the
denominator we don't want that radical
okay in the denominator we want to get
rid of it so how do we get rid of it how
we eliminate it well there's a couple
different techniques now if you just
have a monomial monomial means just like
one group model is one we want to get
rid of the square root of two so what
we're going to do is we're going to
multiply the denominator by square root
of two and the numerator by square root
of two and the reason is is because
square root of 2 times square root of
two is square root of four but what is
the square root of 4 it's 2 right and
then 2 times 5 gives us 10 so we've done
effectively is we've gotten rid of the
square root or the radical in the
denominator now in the numerator we just
multiply across we just say 4 times the
square root of 2 now you can leave it
like that but you want to go a little
bit further there's a 4 in 10 you can
reduce forgoes is divisible by 2 so
that's 2 10 is 2 is what also by 2
that's 5 so basically you want to keep
reducing these two integers as far as
you can ok let's look at another example
so here we have 3 square root of 3 over
square root of 5 again we don't want
that square root in the denominator so
we want to rationalize it how do we do
that well we multiplied by square root
of 5 over square root of 5 now anything
divided by itself is 1 so it doesn't
change the value of the fraction it's
just going to change the way that it
looks they're going to be equivalent now
remember when you multiply what you want
to do is you want to multiply numbers
times numbers and square roots times
square roots so it's like multiplying
like terms so you don't see if there's
like a 1 in front here so 3 times 1 is 3
square root of 3 times square root of 5
gives us square root of 15 in the
denominator of square root of 5 times
square to 5 which is square root of 25
but we know the square root of 25 is
just 5 notice we got rid of the square
root in the denominator we can't reduce
any further so that's it so your
simplified and you rationalize that
fraction ok let's go to some other
examples now these two examples you can
see there's a binomial meaning bindings
2 there's two terms in the denominator
you don't want the square root in the
denominator but what we're going to do
is a little different technique here
we're gonna multiply by what's called
the conjugate so instead of multiplying
by one
- square root of three we're gonna
change that sign in between two the
opposites of one plus square root of
three if this was plus I would make this
- just change the sign in between the
two terms
again you can see we're multiplying top
and bottom by the same thing so it
doesn't change the value of the fresh
it's just like multiplying by one
but what we're gonna do here is we're
going to distribute the two okay so two
times one is two two times the square
root of three gives us two square root
of 3 and the denominator what we have is
a binomial times a binomial we're going
to foil or you can do the distributive
property twice so let's distribute 1
times 1 is 1 1 times square root of 3 is
square root of 3 negative square root of
3 times 1 is negative square root of 3
and negative square root of 3 times
positive square root of 3 is negative
square root of 9 okay so notice what
happens square root of 3 and negative
square root of 3 those cancel because
once positive one is negative square
root of 9 is 3 times a negative is
negative 3 so 1 minus 3 is negative 2
and we're left with in the numerator 2
plus 2 square root of 3 now what you can
do is you can split this up if you want
into two fractions 2 divided by negative
2 is negative 1 over here - root 3
divided by negative 2 can reduce that's
going to give you negative 1 or negative
1 root 3 so we simplified that down a
little bit further let's look at another
example so for this one again we don't
want that square root in the denominator
right that's considered improper but we
have a binomial so what we're gonna do
is we're going to multiply by the
conjugate so instead of being 3 - square
to 2 I'm gonna multiply by 3 plus square
root of 2 and you want to do that to the
numerator and the denominator okay now
because we're dealing with binomials we
can do the foil method or we can
distribute twice so what I'm going to do
is I'm gonna do the foil this time so
first gives us 2 times 3 which is 6
outer gives us 2 times square root of 2
which is 2 square root of 2 inner gives
us 3 times square root of 5 so 3 square
root of 5 okay and then the last term is
last and last so square root of 5 times
square root of 2 is square root of 10
now in the denominator same thing we've
got first which gives us 9 outer which
gives us 3 root 2 inner gives us
negative 3 root 2 and Alaska's
negative squared of two times positive
square root of two is negative square
root of four okay but notice the 3 root
2 and the negative 3/2 cancels so as you
do this more and more you're going to
realize that the inside and the outside
those are going to cancel out square
root of 4 is 2 that's a negative 2 9
minus 2 is 7 and then the numerator we
look to see if there's anything we can
combine there's nothing that we can
combine here so we're just going to
leave it as it is so 6 plus 2 root 2
plus 3 square root of 5 plus square root
of 10 all divided by 7 and you've got it
so I hope this helped you to understand
how to work with rationalizing radicals
better subscribe to the channel check
out more math tutoring videos on my
youtube channel Mario's math tutoring
and I look forward to helping you in the
future videos I'll talk to you soon